a very good evening thanks for joining
us for the Press preview our first look
at Tuesday's from Pages it's time to see
what's making the headlines tonight with
the political editors of the guardian
and the sun Pippa crara and Harry Cole
they'll be with us from now until just
before midnight good to see you both
lots to discuss we'll chat in a moment
after we've had a look at some of those
front pages for you beginning with the
metro misogynists homophobes and racists
that's how the paper sums up the
findings of reports into the behavior
and culture of the Metropolitan Police
which is due to be published tomorrow
The Daily Mail also leads on this story
with the headline broken and rotten the
guardian calls it a damning verdict
the express says the report means the
police must now win back the Public's
Trust
the Ft has more on what it describes as
the shotgun marriage between investment
Bank EBS and the ailing credit Swiss
which the paper says has angered
bondholders
the sum carries an assessment of
Britain's roads which are blighted by
potholes
and the star has less than flattering
things to say about seagulls
and don't forget you can scan the QR
code that hopefully you'll see on screen
during the program there it is you can
check out the front pages of tomorrow's
papers while you watch us discussing
them and to talk about them hippocrera
and Harry Cole are with us really good
to see both this evening
um all the papers uh I've got headlines
about this report coming out tomorrow
and it is Pippa a damning verdict as the
guardian says on the Met police
yes uh this is a review carried out in
the week of the murder of Sarah everard
by Wayne cousins
um into the Metropolitan Police and the
culture
um that exists there obviously the the
awful though the Sarah everard murder
was it wasn't a an isolated case of the
Met police
um displaying potentially
um institutional examples of sexism
misogyny racism
um there's been a series a Litany of
awful stories over the last couple of
years uh really showing the Met police
in a in a really bad light and the
Louise Casey report into this has
concluded that the the forest has
suffered
um a collapse in public trust and is
guilty of institutional racism misogyny
and homophobia
um is it is absolutely damning
um it was 300 or so pages and what at
its heart it comes down to the trust
that the public or lack of trust the
public in London has in in the police
obviously policing in the UK only works
through consent and uh and the survey is
a survey as part of as part of the
report ones that just 50 of the public
have expressed confidence
um in in the force even that's that's
even before the revelations
um about some of the really awful
scandals that the force has been
embroiled in so it is it's not an
understatement to suggest that it's an
existential crisis for the Met it's um I
remember 1999 you both world as well
um there's the the William McPherson
reporting to the Stephen Lawrence's
murder uh applied to the term
institutional racism and to explain some
of it's to explain some of its problems
and 10 years later the force
um it was concluded that that label no
longer applied and while Casey doesn't
suggest that uh that there's necessarily
institutional racism in the force she
does say that that certain problems in
this area persist and raise a question
of what should happen to the Met if it
can't reform we've seen some of the
examples however as one I mentioned
obviously but of misogyny and sexism I
mean these are really serious problems
facing the incoming or the new met
Police Commissioner who at the heart of
all of this is going to have to try and
re-establish trust between the police
and the and the people that they're
there to serve
um it's you know it's a really it's a
we've had many difficult days for the
met in recent times but this really sort
of underlines uh what much of this is
about
um and uh I think you know we're all
going to be listening very carefully
um to what the commissioner says
tomorrow uh once we all have seen the
full detail of this report into how the
message is going to respond and uh and
whether it's going to be able to address
some of these ongoing issues yeah just
picking up on what you said there Pippa
um Louise Casey says uh public respect
has fallen to a low Point londoners who
do not have confidence in the Met
outnumber those who do and these
measures have been lower among black
londoners for years and Harry the front
of the Metro many commuters in London
will be picking up this paper tomorrow
reading it on the bus or the tube and
what a headline misogynists homophobes
and racists
yeah about as damning as it can get in
case you report tomorrow our colleagues
have been locked in
um seeing it under embargo all day and
come back and said it is a horrific
reading and it is a you know it is a
survival issue now for the Metropolitan
Police one of those recommendations of
the review is that if they can't get a
grip on their organization then it's
time for them to be broken up this is
something that ministers have talked
about
for over a few years now of is the
Metropolitan Police too big none of
these problems seem to be like the city
of London police force or you know
Manchester police before they have had
their issues in terms of being put in
special measures for their financing but
none of these issues seem to be at the
Forefront of so many uh scandals
involving the police force met obviously
cover fraud counter-terrorism diplomatic
protection day-to-day policing of London
you know it is a vast organization and
there's a growing drum beat now to have
it broken up and almost start again if
if they can't get control I think it's
interesting I think we're going to see
rally out tomorrow so far tonight my
understanding is that he's refused to
acknowledge
these uh these issues he's refused to
repeat those terms institutional
homophobia institutional racism
institutional misogyny and said he's not
going to put labels on things I wonder
how much of how long he'll get through
tomorrow uh with that line sticking yeah
um uh same story on the front of the
Daily Express condemned Public's loss of
faith in police I mean Pippa 16
recommendations in the report will learn
more uh as Harry was saying tomorrow
um but but one thing that uh is
highlighted is is past leadership and
failings there
yes in particular I think it's likely to
focus on the leadership of um Crescenta
dick who was Mark Crowley's predecessor
who was asked to just commissioner in
February 19 in fact February 2022 after
study Khan said she was on said he was
unconvinced she could lead the mess out
of the crisis he's obviously the London
mayor who's got oversight of the Met
um and you know the report did send
so-called Maxwell letters to people that
were going to be mentioned in the report
that were going to be criticized so that
they could respond so it'd be
interesting to see when we've got the
full detail of that report how exactly
they have responded
um it's like we say it's not this is not
a new problem that the metaphors have
faced we've had seen this going back
um some some decades in fact these um
these criticisms of the force uh I think
it's uh you know pretty depressing that
it's reached this point
um and that it took the Sarah everyone's
murder and Wayne cousins role in that
plus
um David Carrick the uh the serial
rapist his case to show that these
weren't one-offs but possibly how
symptomatic of how serious the feelings
the feelings the Mets have become so
there'll be lots of tough questions
asked tomorrow of the met and of the
people that oversee it and uh you know
certainly the public will be expecting
answers yeah they really will um it
makes I'm sure for depressing reading
we'll find out more tomorrow as you say
um Harry let's move on to this story in
the sun unionists reject Rishi brexit
deal I mean how much of a setback
actually is it for the Prime Minister
um I suppose that all eyes now turn to
the ERG because they said they'd take
their lead didn't they from the dep
yeah it's it's knowing for the Prime
Minister on two levels here one what is
the point of doing this deal which is
you know it's not perfect but it's just
perfectly the enemy of good if that
makes sense in the eyes of the
government
the whole point was to try and get to do
this was to get power sharing restored
in Northern Ireland now the dep the ones
holding out
um against that saying that they
wouldn't go back into Stormwind without
the protocol being fixed this is a
pretty big fix there's slightly warmer
words I think towards some of it uh than
than you might have expected from
Jeffrey Donaldson earlier today but he's
obviously slightly hamstrung by the fact
that some hardliners within the
hardliners if that makes sense in his
party who are adamant that this isn't
good enough and the dup very rarely very
rarely would would count on it as a
split so I think there's still some way
to go in it the language from Donaldson
has left it open for sunac to have
another go and actually if you look at
the wording of the statutory instrument
they're voting on tomorrow it actually
goes a long way further than actually
you could argue the legal tax of the
deal goes so whether there's a way they
could enshrine some things into British
law obviously that's how Boris Johnson
wanted to fix the protocol but soon act
one wanted to do a deal where there's a
sort of fudge that can get it over the
line not necessarily tomorrow but in the
coming weeks will remain to be seen But
on its number one sort of goal of
restoring power sharing installment big
blow if the dep are saying no no no as
they so often do um
is this what you were expecting
well I think Harry's right to say that
the dup wouldn't want to look split and
despite there's obviously a broad range
of views Jeffrey Donaldson on on the one
side and and Ian Paisley and others at
the The Other Extreme who very quickly
came out to condemned the protocol deal
um but because they didn't want to get
split this is really it feels more like
a sort of a holding pattern rather than
a final say and it wouldn't surprise me
if the dup obviously have um recognized
that there is an electoral benefit to
them of opposing the protocol
um if they continue to stick to that
position up until the May elections and
then found some sort of like elegant
position in which they could end up
getting back on board with power sharing
after that point once they've made these
it made any sort of you know they've
capitalized it on as much as it is they
could elect early
um so I don't think this is the end of
the road I don't think this is up saying
absolutely no way forever I think that's
the position now and we'll see what
comes I mean they obviously have made
the point that they their own legal
advice hasn't um hasn't completed yet
and they'll want to see that before they
make a definitive View clear so I think
we should really see what they have to
say about this in a few weeks time okay
uh we'll leave that one there for the
moment thank you both coming up after
the break president XI and Putin have
been meeting but what threat do they
pose to Western stability I will be
discussing that and more in a few
moments time
[Music]
foreign part two of The Press preview
Harry and Pippa are still with us let's
turn our attentions to Russia front of
the Guardian uh Xi Jinping and Putin
shaking hands there all smiles
um Harry do you think China can be a
peacemaker in the Ukraine conflict and
if so wonder what the terms would be
yeah and whether they really actually
want that or whether they would quite
like to see the sort of conflict not not
escalate but certainly carry on it's
certainly in China's interests if being
a cynical interest to have uh the sort
of world's eyes distracted on Russia
rather than themselves but um I do think
there will be a would have been a sort
of stern warning about taking things too
far destabilizing things we're you know
obviously the threats of nuclear weapons
and the like and I think China would
have looked at How the West has reacted
to uh the situation in Ukraine
especially post Afghanistan where it's
clear that Putin took the view that the
West was too divided to do much about
um his stance towards Ukraine and China
will be looking at that how
um
at how they you know how they deal with
Taiwan and whether a similar Coalition
of of of the West and uh Coalition of
democracies and and The Wider world
would stand up if he was to try a
similar action uh in the Taiwan Straits
but it's clear that you know China are
being as helpful as they can without
Crossing that line into lethal Aid at
the moment where they would see
sanctions slapped on them
um in a similar way to Russia they're
provided they're buying lots of oil at
cheap prices which suits them so you
know I don't I can't see them playing
Peacemaker in a traditional sense but
they might just keep putting in check
from going any further yeah Pippa what's
your what's your take on on this state
visit
but it feels very much that President XI
is providing diplomatic cover to
um to the Russians at a time when they
are increasingly isolated certainly
almost
um entirely isolated when it comes to
relations with with the west and Russia
needs allies for uh you know for trade
um for energy
um and uh you know potentially down the
line keeping
um the option of military support on the
table of those Harry rightly says it's
it's likely to be a last resort to that
and I think I can't see
um China willingly uh going down that
path
um but it's uh it's an alliance which
will nevertheless make the West feel
uncomfortable because of the uh economic
might of China and one they would rather
that uh it would rather that she didn't
look like he was he was trying to take
sides here I mean that's a danger that's
a danger for them
um they you know benefits the West to to
maintain that sort of isolation for
Putin this conflict and then of course
the The Proposal
um of a sort of a negotiated solution
part of China's peace plan is is not one
that the West is talking openly about
um at the moment we're not at that point
yet although I was very struck by
comments by Rishi sinak on his way to
Paris to meet people to meet president
macron last week in which he suggested
that that is where this all ends up that
may be the case but it feels unusual and
rather premature for a western leader to
be saying that
um you know at this time
um but that's obviously where
um where Putin and presumably where she
would like to end up but uh like I say
it feels like we're some way off that
just now yeah okay uh let's turn to
um the front of the mirror um Boris
Johnson was we were meant to see Harry
details of Boris Johnson's defense today
but I guess lawyers are pouring all over
it we may get to see it tomorrow before
he gives evidence on Wednesday the
headline the mirror have gone with Last
Chance buffoon
um what do you make of this this dossier
that we're going to see more WhatsApp
messages
I think dossier is quite a loaded term
to be fair if you look at the terms of
reverence of the
um of the investigation the the
committee have put out their side of
event their version of events they want
to question him and they've you know
come to a subliminary findings and
before an Evidence session you know
Johnson has his right to set his views
on it now the committee has been given
10 000 we're told documents most of them
by number 10 under British student
authorizes all that to be handed over
including photographs emails WhatsApp
messages now Johnson's Camp is saying
well look they've put their versions of
events across they've skimmed through
cherry-picked some of them are saying
key bits of the evidence and it's well
within his rights to go through it and
and point to other bits before they sit
around the table and they have a Barney
for four and a half hours five hours on
Wednesday now the was meant to be today
the the process is that this is all
submitted by lawyers to the community
then the committee published it they I
don't suspect they were waiting for 50
pages stuff so when it did drop it we're
told 232 this afternoon it was deemed
too late uh in in the world of official
Doom for for that to that was far too
late in the afternoon than possibly to
get it out in time for the close of play
or indeed dare I say newspaper deadlines
tonight uh and so we'll have to wait for
another day like like this scandal in
many many times at the Scandal we've
been waiting for waiting for a report to
drop it will all come to a head on
Wednesday afternoon two to six we're
told in the House of Commons where um
you know if you believe Boris Johnson
it's a kangaroo caught a stalinist show
trial and if you believe uh the MPS it's
the you know Parliament at its best as
they roast one of their own so
um all the drama still to come but we
might just have to wait a little bit
longer for the details all right let's
get the uh let's get the thoughts of the
journalists of the year for her party
gate Scoops would you would you make of
it all Pippa
well you know we were expecting the
report to come out today Bruce Johnson's
report Harry's quite right of course
Boris Johnson should is absolutely
essential that he's that he's given his
say and given the opportunity to submit
to these documents I understand that
they had to be redacted obviously to
protect some of the witnesses
um which is why um the officials deemed
that they weren't ready to be pretight
I'm expecting them uh tomorrow I
shouldn't have to wait till Wednesday
morning for it expect them tomorrow
unclear at this point whether it's going
to be tomorrow morning or tomorrow
afternoon but it will be really
interesting because we've already had
that interim report from the committee
which found which said that um that the
evidence strongly suggested the breaches
of the guidance the covert guidance um
in place at the time would have been
obvious to Boris Johnson at the time of
the Gatherings this is all about
obviously whether he reflects recklessly
misled Parliament about those Danish
Street parties uh that interim reported
identified four occasions in which it
thinks he did and actually I think quite
a lot of us were surprised by how far
the interim report went
um and how damning it appeared for
Johnson clearly he he'll be wanting to
foresee and you know you can only assume
that the committee will take the all the
evidence in the round with it what it's
gathered itself but also what Brian
Wilson has now provided obviously um
when his uh his number 10 was asked to
hand over the
um the the whatsapps and the emails and
the messages that Harry referred to uh
they sent the move in in such redacted
form that they were pretty much useless
the committee said in August and it
wasn't no vicious and that came in and
then handed over the lot I'm not sure
how that well that will have gone down
with Boris Johnson but nevertheless it's
all night there now uh and we'll see we
should hopefully soon hear for ourselves
uh we will hit soon here for ourselves
uh what Johnson's got to see what his
defense will be and uh and be able to
make conclusions
um about uh whether he did indeed did
indeed knowingly or recklessly uh
mislead Parliament okay um and I'm just
going to have a very quick look at the
front of the sun uh Harry I mean there's
so much going on I'm quite surprised
I've gone with this story but it's a
topic that does get the public talking
well no I mean outside the outside of
the capital where you know the majority
of people travel by bus and train to get
to work you know there are millions of
drivers who are having their cars and
tires ripped to shred it spreads every
day uh by the the shocking state of
Britain's roads I don't think that's a
surprising uh decision to to Splash on
that at all
um what this shows is actually inflation
again crippling another industry the
rates at which potholes are being fixed
this year has plummeted uh compared to
previous years as a construction
industry costs saw councils are broke
last week of the budget only 200 million
extra was awarded to um to help fix
potholes for local councils and the the
MPS counselors industry are saying
tonight they need five times more than
that 49 of Britain's roads are not in
any fit State yeah with a third of them
needing urgent repairs to stop them
becoming dangerous